at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking oil people know I'm a type of
medic organism living tissue over
medical facility this episode is brought
to you by athletic greens I've used
athletic greens for many many years and
I'm asked all the time if you could use
only one supplement what would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is my all in one nutritional
insurance at least that's how I think
about it it is much more than greens
it's a complete whole food supplement
with 75 or so ingredients packed into
one tablespoon per day so when I travel
for instance of course I would like to
follow all of my regimens all of my
pills all of my self-image all of my
food to the tea but sometimes
circumstances intervene and you're too
busy or things are too hectic this helps
me to mitigate the likelihood of getting
sick and to perform optimally so if I go
to say South America for an AcroYoga
intensive which I did in Colombia at one
point I was running around like a
chicken with its head cut off and I took
this every morning and it is extremely
extremely helpful and I usually travel
with travel packets among other things
so you should try it out is the short
version of this as listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show you can receive $100 worth
of travel packs for free when you order
that's 20 free additional individual
travel pouches when you order simply go
to athletic greens dot-com forward slash
Tim to check it out so take a look
athletic greens calm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by Vera
desk and I'm actually standing at my own
Vera desk right now recording this
you've probably heard of research that
shows how sitting all day is terrible
for your health sitting is the new
smoking etc but standing all day isn't
necessarily the answer for everyone
sometimes you just want to sit down and
that's true for me as well the middle
ground is very desk their desks
height-adjustable
standing desks solutions allow you to
stand when you want to and sit when you
need to and as an example I have this
set to the lower position this is a
large model and it took me clickety
clack two seconds to raise this thing up
and it feels like has hydraulics
effectively because I didn't have to use
any muscle to do it Vera desk converts
your existing desk for instance if you
want to get a tabletop version which you
can put on which is very very cool or
cubical into a sit stand workstation and
allows you to raise your desk from a
seated to standing position in just
seconds ships fully assembled so there's
no allen wrenches screwdrivers required
pull it out of the box put it on your
desk in the case of this particular
model no installation or fastening
required there bunch of different
options models start at just 175 dollars
so check out jared Escom to see what
model might be the right fit for you and
my assistant now has one I have one
we've really really been very happy with
it so you're not sure if it's right for
you that's fine they have a 30-day risk
free guarantee which lets you try it in
your own home or office and if you
decide it's still not for you you want
to get rid of it they arranged to pick
it up no hassle so check it out Vera
desk comm lets VAR I desk comm
hello boys and girls this is comparison
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show usually it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers of
different types from the military to
entertainment sports and beyond this
time around you are actually doing the
job for me this is a format that is
often requested and it is around - with
Whitney Cummings in this case the
hilarious Whitney Cummings at Whitney
Cummings on Twitter and Whitney Cummings
calm she's back and you have selected
the questions you would most like her to
ask her first episode was a smash hit
and for those who don't have the context
Whitney is a comedian actor writer and
producer she is executive producer and
along with Michael Patrick King
co-creator of the Emmy nominated CBS
comedy 2 Broke Girls
she's headlined with comics including
Sarah Silverman louis c.k Amy Schumer
Aziz Ansari and many others her first
one hour stand-up special Whitney
Cummings money shot premiered on Comedy
Central 2010 and was nominated for an
American Comedy Award her second
stand-up special Whitney Cummings I love
you debuted on Comedy Central 2014 and
her latest special Whitney Cummings I'm
your girlfriend premiered on HBO she
will also be publishing her first book
later this fall titled and I do like
this I'm fine dot dot and other lives in
this episode she answers a number of
your most popular questions including
how to overcome codependency her updated
thoughts on marriage the art and luck of
creating something funny and she's very
process driven I enjoyed digging into
creativity and art and in generals
production with her of various types the
benefits of having dogs or animals in
general how to maximize your creative
energy tips for more effective writing
and much much more so please enjoy this
conversation with kourosh they rather
monologue that answers your questions by
Whitney Cummings
there we go hi everyone I'm Whitney
Cummings this is my solo podcast for Tim
Ferriss I am NOT going to say anything
about myself I'm sure that Tim just gave
me a very embarrassing intro that if I
heard I'd be consumed with shame / and I
know that his listeners are very into
using their time wisely rightly so and
all about productivity so I'm going to
try to be as expeditious as possible
here I printed out your question so
you're going to hear some papers
flapping please forgive me I'm not as
polished and slick as Tim is so
hopefully that's not too distracting I
know that when I hear bad sound quality
I have a panic attack so don't be mad I
tried to pick the most kind of meaty
questions my biggest fear in life is to
be redundant and boring on a podcast so
I'm going to try to be expeditious and
not repeat myself all right
let's dig in Becca Becca caddy sorry if
I mispronounced your guys's name asks
like a few people on here I'd like to
understand more about what needs
revelations when it comes to
codependency some of her admissions on
the last podcast prompted big changes
for me I'd like to find out more about
her journey has she overcome
codependency challenges will they always
be there maybe some practical tips on
identifying codependent patterns I'm not
mocking you Becca I'm just trying to get
through your question quickly it's a
long one so codependence is such a huge
sort of piece to break off but let's
just dig in if you don't know what
codependency is it's not your fault of
this in colloquial terms I think
codependency is is used thrown around in
a very casual way kind of like words
like genius and hilarious I think we've
kind of forgot what it even means at
this point but be for lack of a better
word clinical definition of codependent
are my working definition is basically
the inability to tolerate the discomfort
of others a preoccupation with what
other people think how other people feel
a concern a pathological concern rather
for other people their problems putting
other people's needs before your own
I've heard it referred to as being
pathologically thoughtful
it's almost like nice gone wrong you're
so nice that you're me and essentially
because when you are preoccupied with
other people's issues and try to take
care of their feelings and take care of
them rescue them martyr yourself on them
you end up ultimately being resentful we
say codependence breeds resentment
let me be more specific just real quick
I am in a 12-step program I'm an al-anon
and I'm in Kota which is a 12-step
program for recovering codependent so it
is no joke it can be debilitating people
can have a couple codependent traits or
all consuming codependent neural brain
wiring which is sort of my deal it is
not something there's no panacea it's
not something you can just fix with a
pill or a shot it's a sort of process of
recovery you never beat it you just kind
of can maintain it let me come back to
that in a second because this all sounds
really vague even to me
codependent can be developed from a
myriad of childhood circumstances
everything from growing up in an
alcoholic home to being raised by a
narcissist or being the youngest child
of a lot of kids so you didn't get a lot
of attention essentially it's a survival
mechanism developed in order to get
attention and feel safe or it's the only
thing you know because you were your
childhood circumstances or conducive to
you thinking this is the only way to
survive I was raised in an alcoholic
home I think it's important to note that
in order for alcoholism to be present
alcohol does not have to be present if
you grew up in a home that was hectic
that was rushed that was a lot of drama
if there was a person in the home it was
an energy vacuum you know this doesn't
mean that they had to be doing drugs or
drinking whiskey at noon alcoholism is a
very what we call cunning and baffling
disease you know you don't have to see
booze out you don't have to see drugs
you just know something's wrong or
you're not getting the attention and the
care that you need as a child maybe you
developed an adrenaline
as a kid I believed that I had something
called epigenetic imprinting which I
actually read about in a book called the
female brain by Louann Brizendine not to
self-promote too much but I loved it so
much I wrote a movie with a brilliant
comedian named Neal Brennan
and made the movie this year that's how
profoundly it changed my life
because I believe that the more we know
about our neural brain wiring the more
freedom we have and the more patience we
have with ourselves that's another story
we'll get to that but I'm trying to be
concise about this but if you grew up in
a chaotic environment inconsistent
environment we're rewarded for one thing
on Tuesday punished for the same thing
the next day as you know children get
confused by stuff like that any kind of
mental disorders distractions growing up
a divorce a trauma or you grew up in a
relatively copacetic environment and
still have a preoccupation with other
people's needs because it gives you
meaning you know codependence can
manifest for anything from exhausting
yourself worrying about other people
finding yourself in relationships or
attracted to people who you can rescue
or thick I find myself I think my
codependent bottom was you know being in
a relationship with somebody who I had
to take care of you know financially
emotionally caused me a tremendous
amount of stress oh I didn't have
jumping around I didn't finish my
thought on epigenetic imprinting that's
when in utero a child becomes addicted
to stress chemicals in the womb because
the mother is stressed out so if you
grew up around the tense marriage and
tension in general any kind of anxiety
low-income homes are particularly
susceptible to this because of the you
know constant financial stress so if
your mother in utero is producing
adrenaline cortisol Nora for nephron
phenylalanine all these chemicals the
fetus then becomes addicted to it the
same way a crack baby would you know a
lot of crack babies are born with an
addiction to crack tragic obviously but
I had a predisposition to be addicted to
adrenaline and I as an adult recreated
my
childhood circumstances by seeking out
relationships that caused me stress and
adrenaline that's what was familiar to
me it felt safe it's all I knew you know
a lot of people I know who have a lot of
anxiety in their life and stress and
drama you know and me before I was in
recovery we lament it and hate it but
yet we find ourselves over and over
again subconsciously gravitating towards
those kinds of relationships jobs
circumstances so codependence more
specifically can manifest in everything
from going to dinners you don't want to
go to going to baby showers you you you
know when someone asked me if they're
codependent and I self-diagnosed I can't
tell you I usually say look at your
calendar and look at your verbiage the
way you talk do you say I have to go to
this thing next week I have to go to
this wedding I have to pick my friend up
from the airport you don't have to do
any of those things
codependence tells us that we do that we
can't say no maybe we grew up in a
situation where we had to do things that
we didn't want to do or had to walk on
eggshells around other people's feelings
our parents maybe our parents were
fragile are very sensitive and as a
result we think it's appropriate or
necessary to constantly go through life
doing things that we don't want to do I
also if you have a hard time receiving
it's very easy for you to give but hard
for you to receive I used to receiving
gifts or help made me really
uncomfortable my comfort zone was
helping other people and focusing on
their needs I never admitted to having
needs before I was in recovery for
codependents I couldn't ask for help I
couldn't say uncle there was no amount
of work I wouldn't take on I didn't know
how to put my health first I gave more
than I had I'm feeling myself being very
vague which is also a codependent
thought we beat ourselves up we obsess
over what other people think about us we
worry that other people don't like us
and it's draining you know people always
say like but I like that about myself
and don't you need that to be successful
and what if I'm just nice
and I help other people and I go to baby
showers even though I don't want to it's
not just being nice
yes you know there is you know the
reason this is such an affair II as'
condition is because it's so socially
acceptable and you can kind of file it
under being nice being in recovering for
codependence doesn't mean you can't be
nice anymore and do nice things you just
your motives change because being nice
for the wrong reasons actually isn't
nice it's selfish if I'm doing something
nice for you because I want you to think
I'm nice that's like borderline
sociopathic right that's manipulative
that's not a pure intention if I'm doing
something nice for you because I want to
be of service with no strings attached
you know that is admirable so you know I
hope that this is a sufficient answer I
don't want to spend the whole time
talking about codependence there's so
much to cover in it but I do think it
might be pertinent to Tim's listeners
because codependents often have a
paralyzing issue with perfectionism I
suffer from this and it's it's sounds
like maybe being dramatic but I really
struggle with perfectionism I can't turn
things in on time staying up till 4:00
in the morning changing the font on a
document you know I've made a lot of
progress but before recording this
podcast I started it I've tried it four
times and I was like hi I'm Whitney that
was stupid hi I'm Whitney that was even
dumber you're an idiot you know that's a
waste of time
so what I would say is that codependence
ultimately it's stressful it's
exhausting it ages you it ultimately
makes people resent you it makes you
resent people it's dishonest but it's
also unproductive so I feel like it
might be helpful to some listeners if
you find yourself wasting time going to
events you don't want to go to being
friends with people that you don't like
I mean before I was in recovery for
codependence I didn't think I had a
choice and the kind of people I was
friends with of course tim says you're
the average of the four people you spend
time with and before program I just was
friends with anyone who asked because I
didn't know I was allowed to say no to
people you know and I took on work that
I
that I was a waste of time just because
I was like I don't do this and they're
not going to hire me for this and what
if they don't like me and what if
they're mad at me like this inner
monologue is really a giant waste of
time and self-flagellating ultimately
and you know something we say in
codependence recovery is that
perfectionism leads to procrastination
which leads to paralysis so when we have
perfectionism we can't get work done we
can't be creative we can't work from our
energy source or from our heart because
we're so stuck in a self-critical state
if that was stupid that sucked that
wasn't good enough not looking like this
you're going to fail that inner
monologue is rewriting that inner
monologue has been a big part of my
codependent recovery if you want to know
more about codependence I would say read
a book called codependent no more by
Melanie Beatty I hope I'm pronouncing
her last name right you might not relate
to everything you might just relate to
some things but I find that you know
this has been a huge part of me sort of
breaking the cycle of codependency which
I think has been passed on from
generation to generation in this country
because alcoholism has been passed on
learning about alcoholism also has
really helped me alcohol used to be in
water before the 1900s as an antiseptic
people couldn't drink water without
alcohol ISM is just such a big part of
the fabric of this country and I think
we're sort of paying the emotional price
now we're kind of the first generation
kind of trying to rectify the you know
repercussions of this disease and it
sort of reaches far and wide let me move
on because I could talk about that
forever Tiffani Savin well she's asking
about codependency as well she's asking
how do you know if you're codependent I
feel like I sort of covered that you
know something else I'll just say really
quick is codependence tend to not have
fun and hobbies in their life this is
embarrassing to admit but before I was
in recovery for codependence I didn't
have fun that sounds weird like I would
go to a party and I'd be like perform I
felt like I was performing fun or just
trying to get it over with I had a hard
time being present because I was still
in my head about having fun perfectly
and it's like having a you know what
codependency is like having a sports
announcer constantly weighing in on your
performance in life you know she's
Whitney walked into the party she said
hi to that guy that didn't go well she
just embarrassed herself why did she
bring that up that was weird now she has
food in her teeth like it's a constant
sort of negative under pinning and
shaming you should I mean I used to have
the inner monologue of you should be
home you should be working or falling
behind you should be working harder you
know for codependence it's never enough
for me I think what I was the last thing
I'll say is you know especially for
Tim's listeners which I know you guys
are all very ambitious people with a lot
of goals it's finding that balance
between overworking and codependent ly
working I think my codependence has been
an engine for me to get a lot done but
it has backfired there's a certain point
where I have burned out and wasted a lot
of time worrying about what other people
think or spending that extra hour making
something perfect in my brain which no
one cares if it's double spaced or
single spaced I could have gotten an
hour of sleep instead recovery from
codependency me to prioritize my health
so that I don't burn out before recovery
and being in a 12-step program I worked
so hard that I got pneumonia so you know
it's I guess
diminishing marginal returns would that
be the concepts don't know where I got
that from but there's a certain point
where work you work so hard that you
actually become unproductive or you make
yourself sick or you're tired or your
friendships suffer or your hobbies
suffer or you know you need a personal
life in order to be I think a good
artist or a good businessperson I
believe in order for art to imitate life
you have to have a life and if your
this person you have to know what people
want if you're selling a product to
people you have to know people so that's
all I will say I'm very concerned time
being a broken record Francisco Israel
asks I would like to see a
deconstruction of what makes stuff funny
what is the fabric of humor like a quick
to be funny manual cheers from Chile I
hope I pronounced that right GLA sorry I
was really trying to sound sexy and it
didn't go well
Francisco I have been doing stand-up I
would say about 12 years I still can't
tell you a y equals MX plus B of Y
something's funny which i think is why I
love doing this so much it's mysterious
its elusive different things are funny
on different people I could do George
Carlin's act and bomb you know louis c.k
could do my act well I mean he's a guy
so that would sound very weird that
actually might be funnier than the way I
do it but if that makes any sense
what makes somebody funny is I think a
combination of the truth high stakes and
bare essence you know Sebastian
Maniscalco I brought him up on the last
podcast but he's fascinating to me
because if you were to transcribe his
act for the most part there's not a lot
of jokes in it if you're to look at a
piece of paper it's in his performance
and it's in his eyes and his timing it's
kind of intangible you know Sebastian is
a friend of mine and you know as a
person he's funny as well but something
happens when he goes onstage that it's
an intersection between him and the
audience so the energy of the audience
plays a really big role which is you
know changes every night the audience is
different every night which means why
something's funny is different every
night it's fascinating to me you know I
think that I do know that if you want to
do comedy or be a writer or you know
even if you want to be a business person
I think this probably matters I think
Apple does a good job with this and
understands the role of surprise
surprise is I think on some level the
most important part of comedy at least
the kind that I do if you surprise
someone
they will usually laugh whether it's the
negative surprise or a positive surprise
you've seen people watch horror movies
you've seen a surprise party surprise is
important and it's really hard to
surprise people these days
it seems like everybody's become so
desensitized so if you can do that I
think you're going to get everything you
want in life you know there's also some
funny stuff that I can't explain I
remember specifically like maybe like
eight years ago there's this comedian
his name is Josh Fadem really funny guy
sort of alternative comedian and he was
on stage at the improv and I remember I
was waiting to go up and I was just a
young you know the kid I had no idea
what I was doing waiting to go on and he
he's very kind of a performance-art what
he does and he does sort of an
impression like a postmodern impression
of a comedian and a lot of levels to
what he does but he started running in
place like in a really dramatic way like
flailing and gesticulated like out of
breath like you can't see me so it's
ridiculous and I'm trying to I'm
actually doing this alone in my house
but he started running in place and it
was really funny at the beginning
because he was like exhausting himself
and everyone's kind of laughing and then
like 30 seconds passed and I remember
being like okay what's next let's go
let's move like you're you're milking
this Josh and then a minute passed and
he's running and it's no-one's laughing
at this point people are just like what
is he doing this person's having like a
manic break he commits to it so hard he
goes for another like 30 seconds and I
remember at this point just being like
angry like what is he doing up there
like this is crazy he's taking stage
time from other comedians like a lot of
Tim Ferriss listeners I'm very obsessed
with using my time wisely and I'm like
this guy's wasting valuable stage time
two minutes about 30 seconds later he's
still running in place the audience
starts laughing again 15 20 seconds
later we're laughing so hard
I'm crying I'm crying laughing the
deepest depths of my gut my muscles are
key
me I had to be I had to leave the room I
was laughing so hard I don't know what
he did it was some magical bell curve of
funny where he committed so hard to
something that we all just I still can't
explain it I can't explain it and it was
one of the funniest things I had ever
seen you know he kind of got past the
stage of bombing and turned it into this
another level of I can't even explain a
performance-art but it was surprising
you know
the audacity that he had in the bravery
and it just it was really amazing to see
and I remember going like oh I'll never
understand how Comedy Works because this
is amazing and let's see I think things
are also funny different times all the
time that's something else is kind of
amazing about comedy is something that
was funny a month ago might not be funny
in two months you know Trump jokes were
really funny six months ago not so funny
anymore you know it got real
you know so that's something else that
is you know you listen to old comedy and
some stuff holds up but other stuff
you're like that that was funny 20 years
ago and it's people are dying in the
audience just crying you know I think
it's definitely harder to be dirty funny
if that makes any sense
because you know everybody has seen at
all these days in the age of porn how do
you how do you say anything dirty
anymore I think what's becoming shocking
changes you know I think when I started
doing stand-up you know this is going to
sound gross but it was a lot of like
AIDS jokes that was like the edgiest
thing you could say now that's not funny
to me at least personally racial jokes
are less funny now that you know black
lives matter and it's it's a you know
ubiquitous on the news sort of all the
racial injustice is race jokes aren't
that funny to me when a white person
does a race joke not is funny what a
black person does it you're like oh I
have permission to let you know
something different happens you know so
it's such a case-by-case basis so I
guess what I would say is that if you're
trying to be a comedian don't worry
about what other people are doing do
your thing whatever your essence is
whatever your truth is I promise you you
are funny and
specific original way talk about your
most embarrassing thoughts and your
personal experience because you know
you're not going to be funny and doing
Daniel Tosh's act that's Daniel Tosh is
funny because of his cellular makeup in
his DNA so I would say just stay
specific and be yourself that's such
weird cliche advice but I guess there's
a reason people say it so much okay next
question um I don't know who asked this
I deleted his name sorry not codependent
anymore I don't even care what your name
is sir just kidding I'm really sorry
please don't be mad
has Whitney's view on relationships
changed since the Howard Stern interview
back in January what is your take on
marriage well anonymous man I assumed
man for some reason I first of all do
not remember what my take was on Howard
Stern cos when I go on his show I
completely black out and have an
out-of-body experience and look down at
my shell of a body from above just
yelling please stop saying what you're
saying because I'm just embarrassing
myself at 6:00 in the morning mind you
so I'm usually half asleep and in a
melatonin hangover so I presume I was
relatively negative about it I think
publicly I've been somewhat cynical
about marriage I you might know this but
I saw three divorces by the time I was
15 very acrimonious expensive Cayce
marriages so I think it was inculcated
in my brain that marriage just was a
giant waste of time and a immense source
of anxiety and stress I now have a
little more mature take on it I think on
some level I wanted to make sure that my
beliefs about marriage were at least my
own and not a result or core beliefs
because of the blueprint I saw growing
up I you know don't want to be a puppet
of the mistakes that my family
and if I'm don't believe in marriage I
at least want it to be for original
reasons so I definitely had a lot of
fear around it until recently I would
say that my opinion has changed on
marriage and the reason that I included
this question is because my reasons for
thinking that I think might appeal to
Tim Ferriss is listeners because I have
a little bit of a casual theory going
about how the most successful people and
the people whose careers I admire are
happily married people I think it
probably is no surprise to anyone that
being single is very time consuming
exhausting and distracting it's a
full-time job especially if your online
dating like I am and I see a lot of
value in finding somebody who can be a
teammate and if the person supports your
goals I think it's a risk that is worth
taking even if it doesn't pan out I
believe in marriage I also believe
strongly in divorce if something isn't
working I think the stigma on divorce is
obsolete and and frankly kind of
ridiculous given our recent scientific
discoveries about Neurology you know
marriage was invented when the life
expectancy was 30 years old we're now
living to 80 it's an unrealistic and
unfair pressure and expectation to put
on people that a marriage should last
forever
if it does that's awesome
congratulations you're an anomaly but if
it doesn't that's okay I hope to have a
couple marriages in my lifetime I just
recently kind of learned the value of
teamwork in a relationship and being in
a relationship this is new to me and I'm
not sure if I've actually ever been in
one of these yet
but I it is my goal to be in a
relationship that energizes you instead
of depletes you
I have historically been into pleading
relationships and an energizing
relationship with somebody who kind of
takes you off the market and out of the
incredibly distracting single scene I
think is really conducive to product
and achieving your goals I think it's
tricky because the kind of people I
think who listen to this podcast and who
want to win in life and accomplish all
their goals are highly motivated and
always looking for an upgrade and to
achieve highly in their professional
lives but I think the people who are
really successful and get to the most
admirable
exelon in their field have very high
standards standards probably isn't the
word very ambitious professional goals
but in their personal life are not
always looking for the upgrade or
looking to achieve highly not that
marrying someone is a that you know I'm
not judging this abstract metaphor but
you know I think it's part human nature
and part a type a personality to always
be looking for something better
improving yourself it's have suffer from
debilitating perfectionism every time
I'm in a relationship I'm like should I
be with someone smarter you know funnier
this that and it's exhausting and I
think that a healthy level of acceptance
of this person is awesome I should
commit to them and yes I could I'm sure
to scour the world for the upgrade but
that's all relative and that's all
energy better used to I think upgrade
yourself and whatever you're doing in
your work so I'm personally striving uh
to the words not complacent but or to
settle but I'm personally looking in my
personal life to find someone who
doesn't make my life harder and if I you
know marriage made sense I would totally
do it if I planned on being with that
person I IX vacations however I think
are have become more realistic I don't
expect my personal life to be 50 shades
of grey every day that's a form of
perfectionism in relationships to accept
the best marriage with the most
interesting person the most successful
person I mean that's all
all those are standards that I would
like to reserve for my professional life
and maybe in my parenting in the future
instead of in my partner seeking because
if someone were to judge me based on the
way I judge others I would never measure
up so I'm trying to just kind of have
not low expectations but realistic
expectations given what I know about
neurology and monogamy and the history
of marriage and what it was intended for
I think I've much more mature take I
recently looked into selling my house
and learned that if you're married you
get to keep a lot more of the money so
that's a very mercenary take but if I'm
with somebody
I'm not going to didn't make some sense
to be with someone for 10 years and not
married I'm just for a stubborn you know
fake qualms with the institution of
marriage you know I no longer think it's
cool or hip to be negative about
marriage but I do have realistic
expectations I think I said before I
believe in divorce I believe strongly in
prenups I don't think that means you
anticipated ending I think it's just a
really smart safety net I think they're
on LegalZoom you don't have to have
money to have a prenup it just makes
things I just think it's a smart
decision I would do that even if you
never use it when you ask for a prenup
or have that discussion you find out who
the other person is so you can also use
talking about a prenup to find out what
kind of person the other person might be
marrying is and I also would never marry
someone that I don't think would handle
a divorce with grace and class I think
to expect a relationship to last forever
I think is slightly unfair because
hopefully I want to be the kind of
person who's growing so much and
changing and learning and evolving so
much that there is a strong chance that
whoever I marry in two years I won't get
along with in 10 because I've grown so
much I've outgrown them that could
happen or they could outgrow me who
knows hopefully I marry the kind of
person who would outgrow me
it was better than I am so anyway I feel
like I might be rambling but I do think
that the hope this doesn't come up to
psychopathic that being in a good
marriage can be very productive and
conducive to professional success
because stability of finding stability
in other parts of my life is energizing
and calming and the last thing you need
if you're trying to take over the world
or start a business or write a book or
start an app is to be having petty
arguments with an immature person all
day you know it would be ridiculous that
we spent all this time with all life
hacks and conserving our energy and for
our body and for our week and then being
in a 400 our relationship right so I
think Tim needs to write the for our
relationship I'm gonna be a before our
marriage be amazing I'd like to see the
person four hours a week please someone
patent that and yeah so all right let's
move on to the next question because I
hear I'm already revealing too much
about my damaged psyche let's move on
because I'm feeling like this answer is
going to make me be single forever
Tom v Mont I hope I'm pronouncing that
right she has multiple dogs in her house
should they ever fight and if so how
does she handle it dog people I know
that Tim just got a dog so maybe you
guys are all dog training information
out but if you have dogs I highly
recommend them they're very therapeutic
they're energizing they have taught me a
tremendous amount about discipline
helped with my codependent recovery
because you can't be codependent and
train a dog especially not a really big
strong dog I have pit bulls that are
just kind of walking lawsuits because
everyone is just so litigious these days
and you have to have incredibly well
trained dogs
if they're stronger than you which mine
are disciplined training with a dog is I
think great practice for being a boss
for running a company for being an
artist for being in a healthy
relationship help you marriage if you
will if I didn't just completely talk
you out of it
getting married introducing dogs couple
thing
know the dog if its rescue which I
highly encourage no the dog's triggers
spend some time with the dog alone first
don't introduce them right away if you
have a dog who already lives in your
home do not just bring the new dog in
dogs are incredibly territorial
especially if it's a female I would also
say make sure you spay and neuter your
dogs always makes them more
confrontational and aggressive if the
dog is not neutered it makes the dog
puts the dog in danger because it makes
that a dog threatened by them spay and
neuter your dogs please
that is going to greatly reduce the
chances that they're going to get in an
altercation or get attacked or attack
first things first take all if you're
going to bring a new dog in the house
take all the food off the floor any toys
anything that your dog might be
possessive over make sure you crate
train your dogs always put them in
Christ next to each other first only
feed them and crates next to each other
at first the new dog make sure you
always give less attention than the dogs
you've had longer you know when you come
in pet the the new dog first the other
dog second treat the new dog like a
redheaded stepchild basically make sure
you are the alpha of the house your dogs
are not going to fight with each other
if you're the Alpha and if they respect
you I'm going to try to make this
shorter because I could talk about this
forever yeah I would say to speed alpha
if any dogs show aggression I instantly
put them down on the ground and hold
them by their front and back legs hold
them down until they exhale and have
acquiesced to you being dominant if you
know your dog well I would you know I
bite them on the back of the neck can
emulate being the alpha dog it's very
weird to watch and not sexy I try to
only improve it those things work for me
I have submissive dogs I've had them
since puppies I have been in experiences
with dogs who are not submissive who I
have not had some Sara puppies that is
much harder and I recommend that you get
a professional trainer if it's a big dog
dogs are animals we can't forget that
they have evolved to read our faces and
to be domesticated and to serve us but
they
also want to protect us and that can be
confusing to dogs and can often cause
fights so if your dog is fighting
probably just trying to protect you or
things you want it to but the key is to
just be the alpha and to make sure that
your dog has really strong recall if
your dog does fight with another dog if
it doesn't respect you it's not going to
stop and if you're just yelling and
screaming it's going to think that
you're participating in the fight and
encouraging it it doesn't know so look
at yourself it's a great documentary
called buck that I highly recommend
about the horse whisperer guy and he
talked about training horses or it's a
documentary on him training horses and
essentially it's about you know your dog
is a reflection of you whatever's going
on with you is what's going on with your
dog so whenever you're training you know
I have this amazing trainer who came in
when I was training my first dog Ramona
and she was a tricky dog she had some
brain damage as a baby abuse pit bull
puppy I was really scared I didn't know
that much about pit bulls and she was
going to get really big and you know
there's so much propaganda and myths
about bulls and but they do have you
know a row of great white shark teeth
and they can hurt you even by accident
if you're if you're stupid so you know
my trainer comes in her name is Julie
Ellis il le s if you are in the
California area she's great does impulse
control you send your dog for like three
weeks and but she comes in and I was
like hi nice to meet you you want to go
outside and meet Ramona and she was like
I'm not here to meet Ramona I'm here to
meet you like what I mean the first
training session she was training me
because any problems that you have
psychologically your dog is going to
have if you're in patient your dog is
going to be impatient if you have anger
issues your dog is gonna have anger
issues if you have anxiety your dogs did
have anxiety
they're very empathic and they mirror
their owners so if you've got an issue
with your dog you might want to look in
the mirror I've had to do that many
times it's painful it's frustrating but
training my dogs has been one of the
most growth inducing edification
experiences of my life
because if you're a dangerous person
you're not a dangerous dog and
it's really powerful really poignant and
frustrating and lots of crying and lots
of anger but it really made me realize
how outrageously inappropriate my
expectations were for other people as
well as dogs you get a dog and you're
like why aren't you doing what I want
you to do why would they you haven't
told them you know what teachers taught
me how to set boundaries to have
realistic expectations to ask for what I
need to enforce my boundaries to be
consistent you can't be inconsistent
with a dog if you say no to going on the
couch five times but you let them go on
the sixth time dogs are gamblers they're
always going to try to play for that one
time that they won you have to be
consistent which is a skill can't be
lazy you can't cook corners you know so
training dogs I think is a metaphor for
life and for work relationships all of
it
powerful cats I don't know as much about
if you're a cat person I'm sorry that I
don't have more to say about them but
they scare me and make me feel insecure
also this is probably going to be
polarizing I purebred dogs I think that
this there's too much breeding and
Embree I have more luck with mutts and
my experience they tend to be a little
bit healthier I've this is a total
judgment and in not a real statistic
this is just what I've seen is that this
pure breeding dogs they tend to be a
little more intractable I've seen some
things go wrong I guess is what I will
say so my other little piece of
propaganda I think you guys probably
know by this point that I'm super into
dog rescue and adoption so if you don't
have a dog my recommendation is adopt
them
I find that mixed dogs I've had a little
more luck with them okay David where
asks ways to maintain creative energy
during overwhelming workload great
question you know I am a sort of type-a
workaholic and until very recently I did
not know how to maintain my creative
energy I would
you know like the poorest boxer from
Animal Farm
I just thought keep working and keep
working and white-knuckle through it and
I don't live that way anymore if you're
having writer's block business
development block whatever you do I
would say you have to chase inspiration
like a rabid hunter you have to be
constitutionally dedicated to protecting
your energy your brain and your inner
child inner child sounds weird I know if
you are do relate to codependency at all
or think you grew up in a some kind of
dysfunctional home the big book of adult
children of alcoholics there is I don't
know the page number but there's a
description of inner child work which is
all about nurturing your inner child I
do believe that we're all just
five-year-olds who happen to be very
tall and have nice clothes and cars but
I believe that we're all essentially
five years old and we forget that
sometimes and I feel like I've spent you
know a lot of the money and time trying
to get back to my five-year-old self who
was focused on play and creativity and
the sky was the limit and colored
outside the box you know I'm not
slamming our education system but I
think we go through this conforming
process in school where we're taught
what to think not how to think and then
we get out of college and we made all
the grades and we develop discipline and
maybe an addict an adderall addiction
but we're become more robots and then
all of a sudden the most successful
people are always the most creative ones
not the robot zombies who you know punch
numbers so I think it's really important
to nurture that inner child part of
yourself
I'll get more specific when I feel
blocked when I'm writing I watch
cartoons I'm not even kidding
I watched recently the old Bambi with
that beautiful animation that looks like
paintings I couldn't watch the part
where the mom died because it makes me
cry I do use adult coloring books I
think those are kind of
vogue at the moment I have one over
there I don't know the name of it but
you can get them on Amazon there's one
that's like serenity one that's
meditation there's one that's kind of
funny that's like inappropriate and
dirty I try to color things opposite of
what they should be I try to color but
not perfectly because as you know I have
perfection issues so I got this one that
is like New York icons and there was a
tab instead of coloring the taxicab
yellow and the sky blue I made the cab
blue and the sky yellow trying to work
the part of my brain of thinking outside
the box and that's a muscle to me and
that's something that I can use when I'm
working so that I'm not doing the same
thing over and over again I don't want
to become a bad do a bad impression of
myself I don't want to repeat myself I
watch people that inspire me Marina
Abramovic I'm a fan I watched her
documentary whenever I'm blocked I'll
watch her videos I just read her
autobiography she inspired me she's
fearless and just a brave it's humbling
she's a performance artist if you don't
know Marina Abramovic
a br a MOV I see it's kind of my dream
for her to be on the Tim Ferris show she
I'll just let you look her up I don't
think I can describe her she's a really
powerful incisive performance artist who
involves the audience as sort of part of
the show and you know I was reading
about how she lived with the Aborigines
and Australia for six months and was
eating bugs and I'm complaining because
I can't finish the last chapter of my
book because I'm tired you know it helps
me to have perspective and gratitude and
reminds me what it takes to be great I
think that's important gratitude i watch
things that I'm a fan of the black
mirror the English version is I believe
I mean one of the most inspiring things
I've ever seen and so I'll go back and
watch it it inspires me I go back and
watch a movie I've already seen that's
brilliant to look for
moments in details The Shining is I
think unbelievable every time I watched
I see something new and I'm like you
know it reminds me that the best artists
the best businessmen are people not men
all of them are relentlessly dedicated
to detail tireless all the things that I
need to find within myself to push
myself over the finish line of whatever
I'm doing I meditate I know Tim talks
about this a lot I was doing
Transcendental Meditation for a while
you know I feel like I plateaued I
started kind of just falling asleep when
I did it I now have a teacher named
George Haas at a place called against
the stream in Los Angeles
he teaches an online class it's called
the meaningful life it's like a ten
month course and I think you can take
from anywhere he puts the videos on
Vimeo and posts the readings and stuff
on Dropbox and it's very specific to
target you know forgiveness meditations
meta compassion meditations that's
really worked for me I think I need
specific things to work on and he helps
you identify your attachment strategy
based on what happened to you in the
first three years of your life based on
John Bowlby theory of attachment very
interesting stuff that's really helped
me again I'm a science dork
I watch TED Talks that's kind of
unoriginal but I just we'll watch it
about something I know nothing about to
sort of awaken the part of my brain
that's asleep I recently watched one on
a girl who animates white for Pixar I
know nothing about animation and it you
know when I watch a TED talk or read a
book about something about which I know
nothing it gives me that childlike
feeling of learning something new and
that energizes me in my creativity I
believe very strongly in brain rest I
know we all want to work you know
18-hour days Saturdays Sundays it's
really important to take time off and
play this isn't my advice or my idea you
know studies statistics science
that our brains do need to rest you know
in order to be productive you guys are
probably all read the 4-hour workweek I
don't need to tell you to take time off
I believe very strongly in rituals
Michael Patrick King who made sex in the
city the comeback which i think is one
of the top three greatest comedy shows
of all time listening to Cujo on HBO
brilliant brilliant stuff I go back and
watch that sometimes when I'm feeling
like I need some inspiration he told me
I need to have a ritual always have a
ritual I often work from home which is
hard because I'm distracted and it's
easy to procrastinate and I need to
clean that and oh I should go make
another sandwich rituals are important
so now I'm going to be embarrassing but
if I'm working from home I don't get to
wake up and just be in pajamas and go
online and you work from pajamas I wake
up I brush my teeth I put on a bra
important to wear a bra keeps you awake
if you're a woman that underwire gives
it extra kick you have to have good
posture when you're being impaled by a
rusty wire
I put shoes on I wash my face I put
makeup on as if I'm going to the office
if you work from home it's really
important not to be a slob I light a
candle I have flowers in my house it's
really important I fresh flowers there's
just something about it that is a
Pavlovian reaction I'm serious this is
happening
I have sage Michael gave it to me ice
age in the morning I do around the whole
house I do a little meditation I kind of
ask for what I want you know please give
me the creative energy to get through
this day help me to be truthful like
whatever I set an intention for the day
whether it's I'm writing a chapter I'm
writing a book at the moment which I've
never written a book before and it's a
totally new challenge for me and you
know my intention yesterday was help me
to be honest today help me to tell the
truth relentlessly tell the truth today
and not hide behind jokes and
inauthenticity and be funny and cute
this chapter just helped me to channel
the truth instead of
trying to impress critics that don't
even have the book yet you know so
setting a really specific intention for
what you want to accomplish for the day
I'll move on to something else because
that's embarrassing to admit this sounds
silly perhaps to some people I've been
reading a lot about color therapy
recently and we all have different
reactions to color but I went to a place
called marrow ball in Arizona with my
friend Neal Brennan who have brought up
already and I went to a color therapist
and he helps you kind of find out what
are your power colors you don't have to
have money to do this you can figure it
out yourself based on what you gravitate
towards and red for most people and me
I'm no exception red was very energizing
for me so in my office I try to have red
things I have a red candle I sort of
have this beautiful vintage book it's
The Scarlet Letter which is one of my
favorite old books I have it on my desk
it just gives me strength whether it's
psychosomatic or not the placebo effect
is in effect so I will take it
Green is kind of a more soothing color
for me if I want to meditate I go in my
room everything's white or moss green it
might just be a fake crazy Hollywood
religion thing but it works for me find
out what colors activate you trigger you
soothe you wear them to the meeting
you're going to put them on if I want to
sort of create a new concept I'll only
wear white because that sort of feels
like symbolically a fresh start for me
I'm sure this sounds very crazy to you
guys but if it works it works right
playing with dogs helps me to
re-energize and to entertain and awaken
the inner child which i think is
important to make sure that your inner
child is honored in order to come up
with new ideas and creative ideas I
don't know I pronounced creative that
way I'm obviously getting tired okay
that feels like enough Chris Brown I
don't think the singer
how does it feel to be in an industry
dominated by men I don't know Chris you
seem really nice but I feel like I've
answered this question for 10 years and
I still don't have a good answer I guess
what I would say is I don't think about
it I see a lot of really powerful
awesome strong women in this business I
love men too so all the men I work with
are awesome for the most part but I do
think that you know know yourself if men
are triggering to you because you grew
up in a home where you know you got dad
issues figure it out it used to be more
triggering to me I guess the most
interesting way I can answer this
question is it used to bother me more
before I got into therapy and got my
[ __ ] together any issues I had with my
dad that made men triggering I healed
I'm still in the process of healing I'm
sure there are a lot of wounds I haven't
even gotten to yet that have yet to
present themselves to me but I would say
you know some I would actually argue
that women are even more triggering to
me I actually had more complicated
relations with women growing up which is
where my codependence Jess stated so I
actually had a harder time working with
women in the beginning I had trouble
with authority figures women triggered a
me feeling like a you know without
getting too specific about my family of
origin you know my mother I felt like I
had to walk on eggshells around my mom
she was very sensitive person and she
worked really hard she had a day job
which I really respect and admire about
her she is a really big part of my work
ethic but she was both working a
full-time job raising two kids in an
acrimonious marriage going through a
divorce later balancing of codependent
overwhelming social life and being a mom
and cooking and cleaning and all of it
and she had a lot on her plate and as a
result I found that it was hard for me
to get attention I didn't want to add
stress to her life I didn't want to make
things more difficult to her
or her and so I minimized my own needs I
walked on eggshells I tried to
anticipate her needs solve her problems
and I became very obsessed with making
sure she was okay so that's where a lot
of my codependence comes from and my
preoccupation with other people's needs
I project that or projected that on to
people as adults but I found that I did
it more with women than with men so in a
professional environment
if I had a female boss or employee I I
tend to recreate those circumstances and
was very worried that all women were
fragile and you had to take care of them
and that they could they were going to
cry at any second and that I couldn't
tell them no I couldn't fire them I
couldn't give them notes on a script
they would just fall apart the way I saw
as a kid so I guess my answer this
question is figure out your triggers if
working for a man is hard for you to
figure out why um you know your boss is
not your dad and your boss is not your
mom your boyfriend is not your dad your
husband is not your mom you know figure
out what you're projecting on to people
that's getting in your way
figure out what old baggage you're
bringing into a current situation
because a lot of times we have we don't
have a right size reaction to a
situation if something hurts your
feelings too much in a workplace
environment it's probably not about your
workplace environment there's something
else going on that you need to fix that
has nothing to do with work and that's
draining and it's old old stuff that you
need to heal I'm really trying not to
curse it's very hard for me anyway I
also you know the subpoena sounds if you
don't live in LA or New York probably
annoying but like I kind of at the point
where gender is not you know I don't
really think about it I know a lot of
men with a lot of traditionally
stereotypical female qualities which is
awesome I know a lot of women with a lot
of traditionally stereotypical masculine
qualities you know a lot of people think
I have a lot of masculine qualities at
least in my work environment
certainly not in my personal life but
yeah so I don't know I don't I don't say
like I need to hire a man for this job
or I need to hire a woman for this job
you know I know a lot of guys
that are artists who are incredibly
sensitive and I know a lot of women who
are you know business in the business I
got such a vague weird 80s way to
describe it who are really you know
calculated and unemotional and all the
things that you would maybe think of a
man is having so we live in a cool time
don't we
next question chip Frank what a name
just like a male stripper from the 70s
in Houston chip Frank's asks if you had
to start all over again no fans few
resources other than your amazing mind
thanks chip what exactly would you do
what's the process assuming you'd even
want to get back to where you are now
that was ominous I don't know how useful
this question is to you guys I guess I
would say you know for anyone who wants
to be an entertainment I mean the
Internet's totally different now you
know something feels very old but when I
started you know YouTube people weren't
getting famous off YouTube I guess if I
were to start now I'd want to do it the
right way I'd want to get good you know
I'm glad that I started right before
people were getting payments off YouTube
because I had to work for it I had you
know I went on the road and I got good I
got really good advice from Gary
Shandling once the late Gary Shandling
who I'm a huge fan of one of my other
favorite shows besides the comeback is
Larry Sanders show brilliant not sandals
not Larry sandals a little plug for
sandals resort the Larry Sanders Show
I'm losing my mind
Garry Shandling in the Larry Sanders
show tweeted blog at Google it he said
to me once it can never happen too late
which was profound for me because I
think I thought and I don't know where I
got this maybe it's my codependence
maybe it's my perfectionism maybe it's a
specifically American capitalism maybe
it's my type-a ambition I don't know but
I thought that I had to get success fast
was all about being as quick as possible
and so if I were to do it over again I
would have done it slower I
think that I got things a little too
fast for a myriad of reasons one was me
wanting it fast you know I did need
money I was broke
what didn't you to get income quickly
but in terms of getting exposure quickly
stand up quicker is very rarely better
you know it's like being a bodybuilder
or an athlete you know that's probably a
bad example because most athletes are
very young but you know you have to get
good first if you get exposure before
you're good it only hurts you especially
with the internet now because you can't
have a bad set and have it disappear
it's online forever and will haunt you
so I guess what I would say is you know
faster is not necessarily better that's
all I will say on that in terms of
having you know staff and hiring people
I would have asked for help you know I
think I made a lot of mistakes
pretending I knew more than I did which
was part of my codependence I thought
that asking for help would make me seem
weak I pretended to know answers to
questions I didn't know which is
interesting because now I always think
the smartest people are the ones that
ask the most questions I'm always so
impressed when someone's like I don't
understand can you explain that better I
never lose I'm never like that [ __ ] I'm
always like this for him it's impressive
to me when someone asks for help or
admits that they don't know something I
think that's a really admirable quality
I wish I had known that sooner I would
have asked for more help I would have
fired people sooner if you guys have
employees you know it's like a
relationship if you have doubts just get
out that's my philosophy I mean not once
you're married I mean you can't just
leave whenever you want there's also
something to be said for fighting and
having perspective and figuring out
what's going on with you first that's
another story but I did not trust my gut
with people in terms of firing them I
wish I would have saved a lot of time
and energy I think I would have made a
better work you know I did a TV show on
NBC and I think I made a mistake of not
firing people sooner because I didn't
want people to be mad at me
I want to give people chances my
codependence is before recovery I didn't
want to hurt people's feelings a lot of
that stuff got in the way of the work
being good I regret that I would not
have wasted time in my personal life on
people that I should not have been
dating you know I was really preoccupied
in I wasted a lot of time let's just say
in bad relationships because I hadn't
gotten my [ __ ] together basically so I
would have gone to therapy sooner go to
therapy I mean there's way that you know
a 12-step meetings are free it's free
medicine these days there's no excuse
you can go online there's therapists
that give talks on YouTube tons of great
ones there's incredible books out there
if you can't afford to go to therapy if
your insurance doesn't cover it there's
group therapy that's cheaper anything
you can get to know yourself and to
figure out who you are and what your
obstacles are and what your emotional
blocks or limitations are the sooner you
can do it the better you know I think in
this country at least there's everyone
goes to the gym people are going to the
CrossFit three times a day but you know
going to therapy is like one of the gym
for your brain
same thing with meditation I think it's
a mistake for anybody who wants to be
successful to not be in therapy or some
kind of game plan to edify your brain
that wasn't a very eloquent way to say
it but that's it I would have gone into
codependence recovery sooner I would
have put myself first I think I was so
afraid especially with what I do for a
living I think I was so afraid of coming
off like I was like a self-involved
narcissist that I I didn't put myself
first I think I would have had more
faith I think I had this mentality of
you know it's never going to happen for
I kind of get it now and I said yes to
things that I shouldn't have said yes to
because I was so worried about I have
such a scarcity complex with you know if
I say no to this I'm never going to get
the opportunity again and I wish I had
said no more because if I've learned
anything it's saying no just makes
people want you more I don't have a you
know proof of that there's no statistic
so it's just my experience
but uh I would have said no a lot more
to people to relationships to
commitments to jobs to even lucrative
money opportunities that ended up taking
up too much of my time because we can
always make more money we can never make
more time I think that's it I don't have
a ton ton of regrets because I don't
think it's fair to sell flagellate and
to live in the past you know once heard
look at the past but don't stare right
look back what can i gleaned from my
mistakes but I'm not going to wallow in
my mistakes it's not productive or
helpful oh this is a small thing if
you're young I would not have cared
about what I wore I definitely spent
wasted a lot of time with clothes what
am I going to wear to this meeting what
am I going to wear to this audition what
am I going to wear to this pitch nobody
cares
I've interviewed hundreds of people held
hundreds of auditions I have never once
hired someone because of what they were
wearing or not wearing if anything I've
lost respect to them for them because
they look like they were trying too hard
so stop obsessing about what you wear
get three black turtlenecks four white
shirts couple pairs of nice pants and
timeless classic shoes and call it a day
unless you're in the fashion business
and maybe that matters I can't speak to
that sorry
eight a question number eight Charlotte
sorry Charlotte Chapman asks with equine
therapy what's been the most challenging
thing to accept and overcome about
yourself as horses are mirrors of your
current state of being on the last
podcast I did mention a coin therapy
there's a place that I go to called the
reflective horse it does have a website
Cassandra is my equine therapist she's
brilliant and Beth Behrs who is on the
show 2 Broke Girls one of my favorite
shows that I created with Michael
Patrick King on CBS she they have formed
a a charity for sexual abuse victims
doing a coin therapy with them you know
a lot of rehabs go there but it's not
just for people have been through
that kind of pain equine therapy for me
was a game-changer because this is so
embarrassing to admit people were
triggering for me I mean I was the
person who would go to therapists and
lie and cajole them and try to make them
laugh and manipulate them and you know I
was more concerned with my therapist
liking me then getting help I mean
there's a lot of things I wouldn't admit
to my therapist much less myself I was
resentful towards therapists I was
sitting there like you know looking at
their degrees on the wall like oh you
went to Harvard like you don't know what
I've been through like I just it was too
triggering for me driving to a
therapists office and then they're
stupid
chairs and they're dumb coffee tables
like it just it was too triggering for
me it was too frustrating I had too much
judgment I had too much self righteous
indignation
I had overachievers perfectionism I
shouldn't be here this is a waste of
time I should be working it was before I
knew that you know therapy actually
makes you more productive and efficient
and effective and creative in your work
and yeah so therapy didn't work for me
at first as much as I'm encouraging
everybody to try it course I grew up
around horses
so I already feel felt safe and a
kinship with them but um you know horses
are prey animals so they are incredibly
in tune to they can read a bobcat's face
and tell us it's hungry or not you know
so they're just they're like a litmus
test or they're a mirror really to
what's going on with you and horses
don't understand lies they don't
understand manipulation or beguiling
charm all the things that we've
developed in order to make people like
us
that's all rendered useless with a horse
horses you know you can be scared of a
horse and the horse understands and will
attune to you you cannot be scared of a
horse and a horse will understand to be
attune to you but if you are scared and
you're pretending you're not horses get
very confused because they don't know
what lying is animals don't lie they
don't they don't have that capacity
which I'm very jealous of so you have to
be constitutionally honest with yourself
around a horse or they won't respond to
you so that to me is just has been a
bullet-proof way to work
the muscle of being present and shedding
all of my what in a 12-step program we
call character defects which is sounds
negative but it's really just kind of
all of those survival mechanisms that we
developed to succeed in our childhood
our family of origin circumstances so
some of us got funny some of us got
smart some of us got manipulative some
of us got negative some of us got a you
know addicted to drugs whatever you did
to fit into your family of origins
dysfunctional system the horses don't
care about so that's really been how I
have been able to acquiesce and work on
not pulling out all the stops you know
I'm trying to think of a new way to
explain it that's not redundant with
last time I was on but I'm kind of at
the point now when you know well the
first thing you do when you go in is you
know she introduces you to four horses
and they're all you know from different
pasts abused in some way this is chief
chief was you know a workhorse and no
one ever paid attention to him this is
so-and-so he was abused by this person
and she then you know whatever their
their backstory is and then she says you
know which one would you like to work
with today and the one that you choose
already is like a Rorschach test that's
already says everything about you what
you're attracted to right and so then
you get to sort of look into why you
chose that horse and what's going on
with you and then now you know I'll just
be in the corral with one of the horses
and for about an hour which is my
nightmare because it feels so
unproductive and I drove all the way out
here and I'm just sitting in a Corral
and I'm not even getting Instagram
photos out of it and I need to take a
selfie for snapchat to get follow you
know it's just you know it's like our
hyperactive you know productivity
obsessed brains and when I'm thinking
positive thoughts this sounds so hippy
but when I'm thinking positive thoughts
and in full of gratitude the horse chief
will come up to me and hang out with me
and I'll be petting him and will
having kind of this amazing moment and
then of course the negative thoughts
creep in and I'm like I should be
working harder I need to go home I need
to do this and this and this this
weekend but that's at that I'm falling
behind and I'm never going to make it
and BA and the horse will just walk to
the other side of the corral she wants
nothing to do with my negativity and
Cassandra will just be like what's going
on which has happened I'm like Lehr
monologue just started screaming bloody
murder and so it's kind of an immediate
way to ascertain your negativity horses
are just really attuned to it and they
don't like it most animals don't but it
also makes you realize what your energy
is what you're giving off you know I
think humans you know when we're not on
our phones and hyper you know distracted
we have that too and you know if you
want to be a leader if you want to be a
boss if you want to be a creator if
whatever your goal is you know if you
have bad energy
you're gonna you're not going to get
what you want you know you're not going
to get the employees you want you're not
going to get the boyfriend you wanted
the wife you want or the investor that
you want you know I think for the most
part maybe I'm wrong people tend to
invest in hire and work with people that
have good energy that they want to be
around you know most of you know if you
work at a job we spend more time with
people we work with and our spouses
right so um you know I think that it's
really important that if you want to
accomplish your goals you need to have
good energy and be the kind of person
that someone wants to be around that's
not like negative and depleting and you
know when someone just has bad energy
it's toxic and it's suffocates a
creative environment it's exhausting and
you know this is that for me it took
therapists could not do it for me I had
to go to horses first in order to get
some self-awareness so that's that if
you you know if you don't live in
California which I'm sure most of you
don't I'm sure you can find a coin
therapy in your area hopefully it's I
think it's a miracle let's see
Aspen janae mol Kathy
the French or am i illiterate Aspen ask
more on therapy outside traditional talk
therapy I resonated with her speaking
about her therapeutic experiences and
realizing she was responding
inappropriately to present circumstances
I feel like I probably literally beat a
dead horse on on therapy so far one
thing I would say is if you have trauma
in your past
EMDR is great eye movement reprogramming
and desensitization look it up I won't
waste your time talking about it again
EMDR I've also had some success with
hypnosis when I'm having like a block or
you know trying to get through something
that has worked for me my therapist does
hypnosis I don't know if all of them do
I'm sure you can find it in your area I
have some great books that I also
recommend if you feel like you're
recreating a childhood circumstances in
professional environments there's a
great book called the drama of the
gifted child love that there's a book
called the tools by Phil Stutz and Barry
Michaels maybe in this book I'm going to
just full disclosure I think it's a
little amateur in places I'm a big fan
of self steps he did a great podcast
with Marc Maron he's sort of a gangster
old-school therapist in LA I've never
met him he you know has very fancy sort
of people but super cool dude and they
wrote a book called the tools and it's
all of the devices I guess you would
call it tools that they have developed
to help people get through blocks and
have breakthroughs for example they have
one that's called reversal of desire
where if you're afraid of something the
best way to get over the fear is to
start to crave what you fear pretty
fascinating to basically live the
worst-case scenario of your fear so if
your worst fear is getting fired for
example or losing your money or whatever
it is or not getting that job or not
selling your app or whatever it is you
essentially have to live through what
that would be like you know it's kind of
like
things through a glass wall the hardest
part is just getting through at them
than you realize you're going to survive
whatever whatever it is that's probably
a terrible way of explaining it and
another one is I think called deathbed
where when you're having trouble making
a decision you imagine and visualize
yourself on your deathbed and basically
what you're going to regret and not
regret them what decision you wish you
had made there's another one called
jeopardy I think where you picture
yourself being I think in exchange
jeopardy and the choices you would make
this is another really good one and I
don't remember but it has all these
little antidotes and stories that kind
of bored me as a type a person who just
wants the solution now but I highly
recommend that book let's see I wrote
some other stuff down that I think is
probably we've covered there's a great
book called sapiens a book by you've all
know a Harare I hope I'm not
mispronouncing that you know that really
helped me because I think that knowing
about your neurology all of our
neurology and our sort of primitive
chemical reactions is very liberating in
order to not change them or harness them
but understand them it helps me have
patience with myself and other people
the female brain by Louann Brizendine is
a male brain as well I think that both
genders reading both are important again
even though gender lines I think are
becoming blurred I think if you're
having trouble with someone at work and
you understand like oh that's just
testosterone you're going to waste less
time obsessing over other people's
behavior if you sort of understand how
they're operating back to sapiens
sapiens is a great book about sort of
how we've evolved and why we have
anxiety you know you know I think
anxiety is I feel everyone has got
anxiety these days and I think there are
a lot of reasons I think a lot of it is
our phone our computer
you know our primordial brain apparently
from what I gather I'm not a scientist
thinks that's the Sun it's very Audrina
lysing it makes us release cortisol
which is a stress hormone we're
constantly in a bent-over position
which I actually on Tim's of podcast
with Gabby Reece and Laird Hamilton she
was talking about how when were bent
over that's a defensive posture when
we're on our computers and on our phones
which is what signals our brain that
were in trouble and and and puts us in a
fight-or-flight response
I think it was in sapiens he talks about
how humans are superficially at the top
of the food chain we don't deserve to be
there it's only because we developed
weapons and alarm systems and doors that
were safe but if you put me in a lion
with a room without a gun I'm going to
lose we're really at the bottom of the
food chain I mean we bees can kill us
that's how vulnerable we are so there's
this anxiety that comes from our
subconscious knowing that we're actually
superficially at the top of the food
chain and could be killed by a bee at
any minute I don't know you know take
what you like leave the rest if any of
that is helpful to you and the question
was Oh other therapy yeah so for me also
learning about neurology has been a type
of therapy for me helped me to be more
productive more patient less anxious or
when I am anxious to have a better
understanding why 10 a question 10 Zack
Edward Dolan wants to know I want to do
stand-up in addition to my normal day
job but open mic night is only three
minutes for performer at our local club
I have hours of material I want to try
out well Zack tough [ __ ] you know that's
very normal I started that way you know
the comedy store open mic was you know
you waiting around three hours to go out
for three minutes what I would say is
although that sounds like a you know
comically a small amount of time the
first couple years you're doing stand-up
you're really just getting comfortable
on stage it's not about the material I'm
sure you're brilliant Zack but I highly
doubt any of the material you have is
going to be in your Netflix special in
five years when you do make it you know
I don't even remember the material I was
doing the first couple years it's the
material assistant excuse to get on
stage and get comfortable in front of
drunk strangers and a very weird creepy
CD and by
terment if you get on stage and you
already feel comfortable congratulations
you have some something terrible happen
to you that that that is your comfort
zone but most people don't feel
comfortable talking to strangers public
speaking I think is one of the biggest
fears it's not the biggest fear so I
would say don't worry about the amount
of time you're doing just get on stage
as much as you can you know when I
started I was doing stand-up at bowling
alleys and coffee shops and I mean
anywhere I could get uh sushi places you
know look on Facebook and and there's a
website called chuckle monkey I think
it's called there might be better ones
that have lists of open mikes in your
area you might I mean I used to have to
drive 40 minutes so this place called
Canoga Park and it was a bowling alley
and I could do you ate it forever to do
Stu minute I mean it's not easy it's
hard there's a reason so few people do
stand-up it's exhausting it's
time-consuming it's depleting I'm not
telling you it's easy but it is worth it
if this is really your passion another
suggestion I have a start your own show
that's something that I did when I
started because I was frustrated by not
getting stage time because number one I
wasn't good no one was going to give me
stage time I didn't deserve it yet and
the places that I could the open mics
are only three minutes so I started my
own show which is a way to give other
comics time but also to ensure every
week that you're going to have stage
time so I hosted a show it was a lot of
work I'm not pretending it's not to book
comics and schedule them and do a lineup
and get an audience and poet but with
Facebook and stuff I mean I'm sure you
can get an audience even if it's five
people that's an audience I did stand-up
at in the basement of the Ramada in Los
Feliz every Sunday for two people or
sometimes just for other comics you
might just be doing stand-up for the
comics that are coming but one stage
sign themselves if you make to make
comic laugh you're in good shape so
that's actually pretty good practice and
you know sorry say start your own show
at a restaurant at a church at a you
know room at a gym doesn't matter just
about getting on stage actually the less
people see you probably the better
because in the beginning
at least I was a disgrace I don't have
any books he also asked me recommend
stand-up books no I don't know any I'm
sure there are some good ones out there
but I would actually recommend instead
of reading how to write jokes book I
would just watch specials watch people
you admire watch bill burr or watch
louis c.k watch George Carlin watch the
grades watch Dave Attell not to copy
them but to you know sort of figure out
why you're laughing write it down when
you make your friends laugh right now
what they laugh at read books that
interest you that you could use as a
starting off point for jokes you know I
read a book I've brought it up many
times I read the female brain and I
couldn't stop writing joke it wasn't a
joke book it's a neurology book but it
sparked creativity in me and became a
lot of the premises that I wrote jokes
about so I my suggestion would be don't
go buy a bunch to spend a bunch of money
on joke books spend much money on
interesting books that will be inspire
you to write material okay what is next
gosh I am winded this is doing a podcast
it's a lot of core a lot of ab work
oh another thing I would say I wrote
this down to remind myself
I mean it's 2017 and you could also
start like a funny Twitter feed to try
jokes out it's obviously a very
different you know kind of reaction it's
not an involuntary laugh but you know
with Rob Delaney and a lot of people
were got plenty Twitter feeds you can do
that from any city um you know try that
I don't know could work a lot of people
are getting book deals and then shows
off of funny Twitter feeds and that's
something you can do from your own home
and not have to drive to go through
three minutes on stage I don't know
maybe next one Chris Nerra
asks with the rise of relatable identity
based storytelling comedic content
across social platforms and media
publishers is it more difficult to write
sets about being perceived as a hack
comedian I felt the need to put this
question in it's redundant so I'm not
going to answer the first part but in
terms of the being perceived as a hack
comedian I just thought it was
interesting because Chris you might be
codependent syi let's date I think one
of the most important parts of anything
you do is not giving a [ __ ] how you're
perceived I promise you that is not how
good work gets done I promise you this
is a lesson I still have to teach myself
every day it is not something that comes
naturally to me but you will never be
able to control how people perceive you
and if you think you can I mean I would
write a book because you will become
very rich you know we all see things
through our own lens right and everyone
is going to perceive what I do
differently
I might trigger them I might remind them
of their ex-wife I might remind them of
their mom I might they might love me cuz
I remind them of their best friend and I
know I don't deserve as much credit as
they're giving me it doesn't matter stay
in your lane and don't worry about what
other people think it you know doing
what we do if you're an artist if you're
a writer if you're a businessperson
everything we do everything that I think
everyone listening to this is trying to
achieve the hardest thing to do but I
think the most important skill is to
make people like you for a living
without giving a [ __ ] if they like you
it's a tricky one to turn on and off I
realize that is my job to make people
like me but I can't care if they do it's
a hard thing to delineate and I'm
confusing myself as I say it but I
believe the skill is detachment you have
to care how people receive your product
but be completely detached about how
they receive your product if you're in a
customer service related business maybe
this is terrible advice
but I believe that when you care too
much about what someone thinks it's a
desperate energy that actually backfires
on you and gives them too much power and
they then start not to like you I used
to be very consumed by people liked me
or not and it was very unattractive and
I felt like I was doing too much and
everyone that we liked actors comedians
they're not begging you to like them
because they're they have a confidence
in who they are and what they're doing
and they like themselves so what I would
say is figure out this sounds so you
know Marianne Williamson Oprah but
liking yourself is way more likeable
than needing people to like you if that
makes any sense maybe it doesn't you
know and it also helped me to understand
neurology and you know codependence and
all this stuff because I I was able to
develop the skills attachment because I
realized that whether people like me or
not or what someone's reaction to me is
a lot of times has nothing to do with me
because they could be projecting all
their own stuff onto me I've already
said that I'm saying it again in a
different way but that was a little bit
of a cheat for me and I stopped thinking
about it and obsessing about it so much
because it's out of my control obsessing
about something you can't control is the
form of insanity something that I feel
like might be good advice that a guy
named Byron Allen gave me this advice I
don't know if you know Byron Allen he I
think was the youngest person ever
hosted tonight's show I don't need to
give you statistics you can google him
you're an adult but he's got a lot of
shows uh he randomly has syndicated
shows on local networks that come on it
sort of 2:00 in the morning I don't I
just know because I get tweets of a show
I hosted of his eight years ago that's
still running and ran
the markets at 4 a.m. very embarrassing
sorry about my haircut weird bangs back
then but he is incredibly successful and
one time he called me into his office to
talk about something and she gave me
really great advice which was don't
worry about getting new fans just
satisfy the fans that you already have
which was like blindsided me because I
thought it was get as many as people to
like you as possible his thing is more
be loyal to the people who already
support you instead of hoarding a bunch
of people who kind of like you getting a
tribe of and now I'm you know
improvising this this isn't all what he
said but but what I would say is find
your tribe of people who really get you
and honor them because if you start
trying to please everybody you please
nobody i'm plagiarizing that from
someone obviously we've heard that a
million times but you know you'll never
make everyone like you it's not going to
happen unless you're Beyonce so don't
bother and in terms of the hack thing
you know I guess what I would say is for
the most part usually when people call
you a hack it's a compliment cuz it just
means you're really popular you know
something happens in the entertainment
business where if you get too much
success people all of a sudden think you
suck I think she's kind of funny because
no other field does that happen no one
like George Foreman grill must suck if
everyone has one sort of like nassima to
logic but you know I think that also
understanding that humans have a sort of
we are predisposed to have like kind of
a primordial need to judge and be
negative I think it's just our tribal us
against them you know it's why if you're
Redskins fan you hate Dallas it's why if
you're a stern fan you hate Opie and
Anthony or vice versa
you know I think we have a
predisposition to be us versus them so
you know when people are like want to
pit me against other female comedians or
podcasters against podcasters or compare
it's a natural human nature thing that I
try not to take too personally
I'm just grateful to be in the ring and
in being able to do what I love so I
just try to stay in gratitude because
for my personality that's that's the
only place that I can find sanity and if
someone is judging me to feel better
about themselves I just I want to send
them compassion because I do that and
when I do it it usually means I feel
insufficient or jealous or insecure so
but that's just me
maybe I'm being delusional um but guess
what it's working anyway so
Byron's thing you know he also had this
he said in order to be like a huge
success you really only need about a
million people to like you he was
pointing out a really successful
comedian who was like a household name
at the time and you know making a
million dollars a night selling out
these huge arenas and and he did the
math on on how many people were seeing
his shows I'm awful at math so I'm not
going to pretend I know how to do this
but he kind of broke it down for me
and he was like you know 20,000 seats if
you're selling 20,000 seats a night
times fifty cities and you know selling
$60 tickets like you really only need a
million people out of 380 million people
in America so you don't even need one
percent of people to know who you are in
order to be a household name and really
successful so stop trying to get 10
million just don't lose the 1 million
who like you by selling out trying to
get the other 300 million I thought that
was good advice
Jaime LeBlanc says Jaime LeBlanc soo are
you French
I hope so given the cons of each facet
what keeps her motivated and which is
her favorite writing stand up acting etc
I don't know I believe in order to be
good at one thing you have to do a lot
of things maybe that's just how my brain
works I get bored and I think that all
of these things reinforce each other I
think in order to be a good boss you
need to know what it's like to be an
employee I think in order to you know
sell an app you have to know what it's
like to need that app if you get into
the head of you know your consumer or
your you know I think in order to be a
good stand-up you have to know what it's
like to be in the audience you know
I'll go see stand-up shows as a patron
you know I think it's important you know
I think I recently directed a movie and
it made me a better actor how weird is
that because I learned about you know
continuity like when you're acting and
you're picking up props and stuff you
have to do it the same way every time or
else in editing we can't cut it together
so if an actor has bad continuity like
for example each line they're supposed
to pick up the coffee cup at the same
time they pick it up at a different time
each tape
we can't edit them together so they may
have a brilliant performance but they
picked up the coffee cup in the wrong
time so I can't use it
so I've done jobs before where I'm like
why do they use that take now wasn't my
best take that was my best performance
how dare they but I probably made a
continuity mistake which rendered my
good cake useless so I think for me
being a writer being actor being a
stand-up being a writer director makes
me better at everything and I also think
it's a skill to know what belongs where
so if you're a writer for example or
creative person you know I had a lot of
sort of stories that weren't funny
enough to be in stand-up but I'm trying
to make it a stand-up joke and I
realized oh this is a movie idea this
isn't a fan of joke or this should be in
a book or I'm writing a book right now
and I'm like the shitty Stan of joke I'm
not going to put this you know it's it's
too jokey to put in a chapter feels
desperate I should do this on stage you
know so I think having a lot of
different outlets is good you know if
you're really creative person and you
have a podcast and you have a blog and
you have an app and you have a book you
know knowing what goes where I think is
a strong skill to have one that I'm
still honing but I kind of like all of
it because I think you know it's like oh
in the gym you have to do leg this arm
I'm not going to him that much obviously
but you got to do every part of the body
I also think you got to work every part
of the brain anyway that's that I hope
that made some sense
stand-up however is probably my favorite
thing to do it's the most thrilling it's
like walking on a tightrope it's you
know I think everyone should do it even
if you know I hoped him
decides to jump off that Cliff at some
point I think that stand-up is like
skydiving or something I think everyone
should do it at some point actually I
take that back
I don't think anyone should skydive I
think it's ridiculous I've never done it
never planned on doing it I'm just
saying the feel of stand-up is that
thrilling and I think you really find
out who you are when you do stand-up
it's a truth serum and I think everyone
should do it at least once just to try
it as a life experience I highly
encourage it but it makes me feel very
awake alive it makes me tell the truth
because the audience only responds to
the truth and as somebody who you know
some as a performer sometimes I want to
perform and the audience doesn't let you
the audience is a litmus test in a lot
of ways and like courses forces you to
be honest and as someone who you know as
a kid developed the skill of being
dishonest in order to be liked and to
maintain equilibrium in a hectic home I
need that I need a reminder to be honest
all the time which sounds sad and dark
but I think a lot of us you know are
taught as kids man up don't cry it's
fine calm down and you know we are
constantly inculcated with those
messages as children and as a result I
think a lot of us develop these we
pretend we pretend we're fine when we're
not we pretend things are funny when
we're not laughing we pretend to be
interested in boring conversations we
lie all day every day and it's
exhausting so I am trying to deactivate
that you know superpower which worked
really well as a kid because I got good
grades and I you know my parents I
didn't get grounded and I've gotten to a
college because of all of this sort of
pretending I was fine and pretending I
was this and that and pretending is
draining and unoriginal and it's feels
like you're sleepwalking through life
and and acting through life it's getting
very personal isn't it next one Jen
bales says
what steps or advice would she give
someone who wants to get their TV script
in front of the right people how do you
get people to read your work especially
for those who aren't living in LA Jen I
don't know I felt like I needed to
include a question with an answer I
didn't know the answer to because I'm
sure a lot of people have that question
I am sorry to say this I do think you
have to live in LA or New York and
hustle you know I started doing stand-up
and I became a writer on a late-night
show and started writing scripts and I
had a manager who you know I kind of you
know I had an oblique angle I mean I was
doing stand-up but um I don't know how
people do that I have to be really
honest with you I don't think you can
just blind submit to agencies I would
say yet of what I see success in now is
people having successful funny Twitter
feeds successful YouTube videos blogs
podcasts they come out to LA or New York
they do shows at comedy clubs in UCB and
you know that's how it happens and
there's you know there's Chicago there's
Portland has the comedy scene Denver is
a big comedy you know I do think you
might have to be in a metropolitan city
so as annoying and as expensive as that
sound I do think that that's a big part
of it from what I have seen
statistically that seems to be what
works but I would say you can't have
someone read your script until you write
it so write a script read scripts watch
episodes of great shows Cheers
Mad About You pilot watch great shows
watch shows that you liked write specs
for those shows a spec is an example
like a episode of a show that you'd want
to write for you can write a spec for
the office for example on you're not
gonna get a job on the office because
it's not on anymore but people then read
that spec and they go oh this person can
write for this show they can write for
they have a voice but they also can
conform to the voice of show they're big
and create so if I'm hiring a TV writer
I read a spec script they write a spec
for How I Met Your Mother or Modern
Family or whatever it is you cannot
submit a spec to a show that you that is
the show so if you want to write on two
Broke Girls I can't read a two Broke
Girls spec
because it's a legal nightmare and
you'll sue me and you know it's happened
and continue to happen so if you want to
write for Big Bang Theory don't write a
Big Bang Theory spec write a Mike and
Molly spec or something else that's
currently on and try to get it to an
agent and get to a metropolitan city as
savage and cold-blooded as that sounds
okay we have to wrap this up soon I feel
like this is this is going on really
long Addie Siegel where do most of your
ideas and jokes come from do they jump
to your mind while you're doing other
things shower gym etc or is there
specific thinking process a little bit
of both you know again I think you have
to be relentless in your pursuit of
inspiration I read the news every
morning I read books I you know ask
people questions you know I'm really
annoying to have dinner with because all
I do is ask questions about your
personal life and your sex life and your
do you believe in religion and who are
you I'm trying to mine for jokes and
spark of something or I'm always kind of
subconsciously or consciously building a
case for material I have so if I decide
you know the thesis of which I mentioned
earlier which again I believe sounds
slightly mentally ill that marriage
married people are more successful for
happily married let's say that but
people in stable relationships if I'm
with a successful person I'll ask them
about their marriage and how is it and
do you fight and what do you fight about
and how often do you fight and do they
support your career that's up to that
I'm building a case trying to be a
comedian for me at least kind of like
being a scientist like you have to come
up you know Chris Rock said this that
you have to come up with a ridiculous
theory and then prove it
so you know for example cars are like
women ridiculous theory right that's not
that ridiculous but you know what I mean
something no one's ever heard before
like a big comparison or simile cars are
like women and then you prove it
they've the jokes you know to get a new
one every three years they come in six
colors whatever the funny proof is right
they lose their value as soon as you
take them off the lot etc etc insert
funny joke here so
I guess I'm always sort of looking for a
ridiculous theory to prove or something
common or annoying usually when
something annoys me or keeps me up at
night I want to write about it anything
that's you know Neal Brennan I just
really need to credit everybody I'm
quoting says you know comedians are
obsessed with justice I think that's
true louis c.k says if you think about
something more than three times a week
you need to write a joke about it so
that's that let's see oh I also would
like to say that in the first podcast I
did with Tim I feel like I wanted you a
redo on my billboard when he says if you
could have a billboard anywhere what
would it say I don't remember what I
said but I remember panicking I listened
to Tim show but I remember being like
I'm not going to listen on it's going to
go on and I'm going to be authentic and
I'm just going to tell my truth and
channel whatever the viewers need to
hear and that I got on there and I was
like I should have prepared for this the
Billboard question really stumped me and
I felt very dumb and like I bombed it
and I now have a better answer that I
would like to say which is I'm
plagiarizing from Peter Berg the
director who was you know brilliant man
he did Friday Night Lights and he's
great and is a dear friend and has
taught me a lot really smart dude
he once sent me an e-mail or whatever it
was just with the word I was going
through a hard professional time and I
was struggling and he just wrote in
capital letters finish the word finish
fi n is H finish this sounds really
simple and obvious but it is something
that was that I needed to hear because I
think anyone listening to this podcast
myself included I want to do so many
things there's so I so many ideas anyone
can have ideas but the ones that succeed
are the ones that execute and pushed
across the finish line and for me those
last three steps that last sprint is
always the hardest for me because I'm
tired and I lose enthusiasm and I feel
resentful and entitled
that I've worked this hard and meaning
me finish you have to finish what you
start you know I was the person who had
five books by my bed and I had read only
chapter one I'm the person that wrote
started four scripts and finished zero
do one thing at a time and finish it
instead of doing five things and not
completing them that formula I believe
having done both I've had more success
with with this one starting thing
doesn't count no one wins awards for
starting a script no one's going to read
a script that's 12 pages it's got to be
a hundred pages you can start things all
day long but if you can't finish them
you're wasting everybody's time so that
would be my billboard I just felt the
need to my ego felt the need to improve
upon my answer and I'm sure you've all
done it we've all been like oh I thought
of that problem I thought of uber I
thought of tinder lah but some other
guys finished it right and executed it
so you know I think that uh committing
to one thing is admirable I have a very
hard time with that I'm not saying I
know how to do it well but if you do I
will be working for you one day another
quote I'll close with this quote
Benson Bharti he a quote that I really
love he says inches make champions
inches I tend to think in miles and feet
but sometimes it comes down to inches
and that's something that I used to have
on my computer on a little post-it note
I don't really know how to dismount on
this I hope that this was helpful I hope
that I wasn't blathering too much on
boring you guys oh I wish it was funnier
but I don't think that that's what this
was supposed to be so I'm just going to
release my self-criticism okay I have to
log in to undo this okay I hope you guys
are happy and thank you for listening if
you've even gotten this far I hope this
is useful in any way I'm on Twitter at
Whitney Cummings I'm on snapchat I'm on
all of it I try to engage as much as I
can with people on social media Tim I
think has got all the books and stuff
that I talked about I'm sure he'll put
on his
eight I'm actually writing a book at the
moment which is going to come out in the
fall and I hope to include a lot of this
stuff because people seem to be
responding to you know kind of the
healing our brains in order to be better
at what we do and more productive and
effective and live more fulfilling lives
so I hope that you guys I can finish
this book which is why I have to get off
stop recording this podcast because I
have to write the goddamn book and
finish it look at us okay thank you
let's field anti-climactic love you bye
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is 5 bullets writing do
you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend and
five bullet Friday's a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird ships that have somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy this
episode is brought to you by Vera desk
and I'm actually standing at my own véra
desk right now recording this you've
probably heard of research that shows
how sitting all day is terrible for your
health sitting is the new smoking etc
but standing all day isn't necessarily
the answer for everyone sometimes you
just want to sit there and that's true
for me as well the middle ground is very
desk very desk height adjustable
standing desk solutions allow you to
stand when you want to and sit when you
need to and as an example I have this
set to the lower position this is a
large model and it took me
clickity-clack two seconds to raise this
thing up and it feels like has
hydraulics effectively ii have to use
any muscle to do it vera desk converts
your existing
for instance if you want to get a
tabletop version which you can put on
which is very very cool or cubical into
a sit stand workstation and allows you
to raise your desk from a seated to
standing position in just seconds
ships fully assembled so there's no
allen wrench and screwdrivers required
split out of the box put it on your desk
in the case of this particular model no
installation or fastening required
there's a bunch of different options
models start at just one hundred and
seventy-five dollars
so check out jared Escom to see what
model might be the right fit for you and
my assistant now has one I have one
we've really really been very happy with
it so you're not sure if it's right for
you that's fine they have a 30-day risk
free guarantee which once you try it in
your own home or office and if you
decide to still not for you you want to
get rid of it they arrange to pick it up
no hassle so check it out bear odesk.com
that's a VAR RI desk dot-com this
episode is brought to you by athletic
greens I've used that betta greens for
many many years and I'm asked all the
time if you could use only one
supplement what would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is my all in one nutritional
insurance at least that's how I think
about it it is much more than greens
it's a complete whole food supplement
with 75 or so ingredients packed it into
one tablespoon per day so when I travel
for instance of course I would like to
follow all of my regimens all of my
pills all of my cell phones all of my
food to the tee but sometimes
circumstances intervene and you're too
busy or things are too hectic this helps
me to mitigate the likelihood of getting
sick and to perform optimally so if I go
to say South America for an AcroYoga
intensive which I did in Columbia at one
point I was running around like a
chicken with its head cut off and I took
this every morning and it is extremely
extremely helpful and I usually travel
with travel packets among other things
so you should try it out is the short
version of this as listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show you can receive $100 worth
of travel packs for free when you order
that's 23 additional individual travel
pouches when you order simply go to
athletic greens dot-com for flash Tim to
check it out go take a look at what it
greens.com forward slash camp
[Applause]